do you have some questions about the
upcoming Hellboy film questions like why
film a reboot at all why is it r-rated
or if you're new to this whole scene
perhaps you're just wondering who
Hellboy is in the first place
well we're here to help Hellboy was
originally conceived in 1991 by comic
creator Mike Mignola
and appeared in various one-off stories
and illustrations before his own title
arrived in 1994 despite his bright red
horned humanoid appearance Hellboy is
technically only half-demon as the
comics established him to be the child
of a Duke of hell and a human which born
in Hell after his mother's body was
taken there by his biological father
Hellboy was summoned to earth in 1944 as
the result of a Nazi occult ritual led
by the sorcerer grigori rasputin in the
comics he appears in England where
American soldiers and Professor Trevor
Broome are investigating Nazi activity
but nevertheless a name we all came to
use we called him
Hellboy over time it became clear that
the young Hellboy was despite his
appearance an apparently good soul and
in a matter of years he was recruited to
become the world's most effective
paranormal investigator working with
broom as his mentor and surrogate father
Hellboy travels the world battling
various paranormal threats as a
half-demon Hellboy possesses
extraordinary strength and durability
that allow him to continue fighting well
past human limits perhaps most
importantly he's basically fireproof
which makes sense for someone who's half
Hellspawn then there's the matter of his
right hand
and beheld an angel and in his right
hand the key to the bottomless mate
known as the right hand of doom it was
grafted onto his infant body by his
father at birth the hand originally
belonged to an ancient spirit called
Anam who is the creator of odd drew jaha
legendary imprisoned creatures who were
prophesized to one day be released and
bring about the end of the world hell
boys right hand is key to releasing and
controlling the augiejhu jihad
even if Hellboy himself would rather not
be on that it's also a big heavy hand
that he can use to hit monsters with and
more recent comic book stories Hellboy
has assumed greater control over his
demonic form to the point that he can
manipulate his own size and even sprout
wings and pull horns when he wishes
although this is generally not an
ability explored in film versions of the
character yet in the 2019 Hellboy milla
jovovich plays Nimue a originally known
as the Lady of the lake
Nimmo a is a being from Arthurian legend
that was a powerful witch and extremely
close to Merlin Merlin told her all of
his magical secrets but she ultimately
imprisoned him and went mad with the
dark knowledge she was eventually killed
when all the other witches of Britain
banded together to kill her and seal her
body deep in a tomb in the comics story
The Wild Hunt
Nemo a is resurrected after she's
nominated to become the leader of The
Witches of Britain many of whom flee and
terror from her power it's during this
storyline that Morgana lafay reveals to
Hellboy that he's actually the last heir
of King Arthur setting up a showdown
between Hellboy and Nimmo a that could
bring about the end of the world suffice
it to say Nemo way is bad news indeed
Hellboy wouldn't be who he is without
Professor Trevor Broome the man who
found and essentially adopted him in
1944 when he first appeared on earth
broom is an English a cult expert who
began working with Allied forces in
world war ii when it became clear that
the nazis were planning to call demonic
forces to earth after the war broom
helped form the Bureau of paranormal
research and defense and he and Hellboy
battled various occult threats together
until brooms retirements as director of
the agency in the comics broom was
killed in 1994 by a frog monster tied to
the augiejhu jihad and had a similarly
gruesome end in 2004 Hellboy movie
he was played by John Hertz in both the
original and 2008 Hellboy 2 the Golden
Army and is played by Ian McShane in the
2019 film throughout his comic book and
cinematic history
Hellboy has retained close ties to the
Bureau of paranormal research and
defense for BPRD the bureau's mission
statement is right there in its name
there are things that go bump in the
night
aging mind's eye no mistake about that
and we are the ones who pump back it's
job is the research and combat various
occult threats and phenomenon that may
pose a threat to humanity often with the
aid of various supernatural entities and
humans who have been gifted with special
abilities Hellboy is the most
predominant of these members but the
Bureau has also included members like
the fish man Abe Sapien and the
pyrokinetic human Elizabeth Sherman and
a 2009 teen film the BPRD also includes
Ben daimyo a BPRD agent who was killed
by a Jaguar cult on assignment in
Bolivia daimyo rose from the dead and
has since manifested the ability to
transform into a jaguar creature in
november of 2018 a last-minute casting
edition was announced for the new
Hellboy film Thomas Haden Church joined
the reboot as lobster Johnson a
character created by Mike manola in 1999
as an homage to various pulp heroes of
the early 20th century in the comics the
lobster was a vigilante and depression
heir in New York City known for burning
his lobster emblem into the flesh of
criminals to the public he was thought
to be an urban legend and eventually a
fictional character dreamed up by a pulp
writer instead the lobster was real
enough to begin working for the US
government in the late 1930s in an
effort to thwart various Nazi missions
he died in 1939 while attempting to stop
a Nazi space launch that would have
possibly put the Third Reich into space
in 2001 he appeared in the Conqueror
worm storyline as a ghost who haunts the
ruins of the castle where he died he's
made occasional appearances in the
comics since leading a ghostly helping
hand to the BPRD against supernatural
threats the first two Hellboy films were
mastermind by director Guillermo del
Toro with Ron Perlman in the title role
Hellboy 2 the Golden Army ends with a
hint for more Hellboy story to come
unfortunately the film under
performed and a planned third movie
didn't materialize as years went by del
Toro continued to express interest but
in early 2017 he announced that all
efforts had finally been exhausted
months later the reboot was announced
without del Toro attached
according to Hellboy creator Mike
Minneola there was some talk of trying
to continue del Toro story with a new
film but he felt that wouldn't be fair
to a new team of filmmakers he told
sci-fi that he was looking forward to
director Neil Marshalls take in the
summer of 2017 the Hellboy reboot
ignited an uproar with a casting
announcement ed skrein was confirmed to
play Ben daimyo in the comics daimyo is
a Japanese American and this heritage
plays a major role in both his life and
in the BPRD comics stories fans were
confused and upset that the production
didn't cast a Japanese American actor to
better to pick the character on screen
scrying became aware of the outcry after
taking the role and released a statement
saying he would be departing the
production to make room for another
actor then in September 2017 Korean
American actor Daniel Dae Kim signed on
to play the role of Ben daimyo thanks to
the cast and crew's willingness to
correct themselves we got a Ben daimyo
who looks more like the Ben that fans
were introduced to on the comics page
both of Hellboy's previous big-screen
adventures were pg-13 rated fantasy
adventures with certain horror elements
however in 2017 Hellboy director Neil
Marshall remarked that he had been
granted permission to take the film into
our rated territory what she saw not as
a mandate but as a license to depict the
same level of violence often explored in
comics in February of 2019 the Hellboy
reboot was officially rated R for strong
bloody violence and gore throughout it
also earned that rating because of
language star David Harbor explained to
MTV it goes R for like a bit of gore and
horror but also a bit of just the mature
aspect of and the mature themes of it
just that we're dealing with complicated
subject the first Hellboy film was a
loose adaptation of his first major
story seed of destruction the sequel the
Golden Army was an original story
conceived by Guillermo del Toro and the
third film would have followed that
concept more the reboots Mineola and
company didn't necessarily want to
retell the characters origin story but
they did want to draw heavily
from the original comics that means that
much of Hellboy 2019 will come from
various Hellboy comics the Wild Hunt
darkness calls the storm in the fury and
Hellboy and Mexico are just some of the
storylines that have been clearly
referenced in trailers and interview
junkets in terms of the look of the film
concept artist pulled direct inspiration
from comics by manola and other artists
then adapted them to a more real world
look makeup artist Joel Carlo told Syfy
what we wanted to do with the character
was to make him feel grittier to feel
not so much like a comic character what
would this character look like if he was
in the real world
hence the addition of the scars and the
addition of the hair and the overall
sort of weathering on him that you do
find in the illustrations David Harbor
became a star in the eyes of genre fans
thanks to his role as chief hopper in
stranger things a role that gave him the
prominence necessary to get a
blockbuster job like Hellboy plain
Hellboy created a different set of
challenges for harbor though and not
just because of the prosthetic
applications and all the stunt work
playing Hellboy also meant stepping into
a role already made famous by Ron
Perlman so how did harbor decide to take
the job by finding a new approach to the
source material barber told The
Hollywood Reporter that he struggled
with whether or not to do the film I'm a
fan of those movies saying Guillermo is
obviously an extraordinary director and
Ron's an extraordinary actor and his
definition of that role was very iconic
so in terms of approaching it even when
they approached me I was like why do it
it's already been done and they said
they wanted to do it differently and
there's something when you go back to
the actual graphic novel that is a bit
darker and a bit less clean and even in
terms of the character arc of Hellboy
himself this piece focuses a little more
on his internal struggles I equate it to
Hamlet's a little bit it's got a certain
Hamlet feel to it presumably there's a
little more action in this version of
Hamlet to be
oh not to be not to be check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you